alors je vous adore mais ça vous met
très en valeur
merci on avait dû mettre une chemise de
vacances ce soir c'est fou c'est pour ça
mais ça va mon chéri ça va que vous
allez revenir sur quoi mon bébé alors je
retiens surtout c'est passé la semaine
dernière en touche pas à mon poste
d'accord et non ceux que ça intéresse
tous nos invités sarr s intéresse les
gens et c'est vrai que tous les jours
avant touche pas à mon poste il ya mon
émission préférée à c'est que la télé
présenté par la beyoncé de casablanca et
chez vous je vous imaginez un instant
valérie bénaïm valérie bénaïm c'est que
de la télé plus tpm peut imaginer comme
patoche et heureuse
[Rires]
hollande a égrené libre à partir de 17h
il travaille pas tort il a plus besoin
d'un break rapidement à la maison à
s'occuper de votre fils de 46 ans
j'adore cette émission j'ai travaillé
longtemps et ça que ça s'appelle c'est
que nathalie mons et pas pourquoi
puisqu'ils parlent jamais de télé on
sait bien et dans cette émission
notamment le plus grand nutritionniste
de france jean michel cohen et je vous
rappelle que jean michel cohen c'est
quand même le seul très sioniste qui a
plus de poids à perdre que c'est pas si
c'est pas vrai il fait le nono en
général fayez plus en bas qu'en restant
alors est ce que vous aimez c'est que de
la télé cyril j'adore je suis producteur
cette émission et je suis fier d'être le
producteur de cette émission qui
vraiment fait un carton d'audience
bravo valérie bénaïm merci c est
renouvelée l'année prochaine mais le
juge renvoie l'ascenseur vendredi à quoi
alors nous le vendredi
alors le vendredi justement c'est un
jour que je vais enlever de la semaine
demander des dérogations alors est ce
que vous êtes sûr que vous aimez c'est
que de la télé oui j'adore être sur wii
ça se voit pas trop quoi 4 % des couples
qui ont passé plus de dix ans ensemble
ont déjà fait une fois un plan à trois
qui est dur vous non aller à trois dents
c'est trop loin d'accord cela nous a
fait une vanne c'est qu'au-delà de
regarder votre thé de cyril quand une
ancienne de ces que de la télé fait un
lancement de vidéos vous aimez l'espagne
bien sûr j'adore l'espagne mozzarella
ça tombe bien on va aux états unis on va
dans le colorado
on a trouvé des preuves que vous qui
fait le programme de valérie bénard vous
vous rappelez même plus du nombre des
missions vous produisez sachez que
valérie bénaïm était un petit peu
souffrante elle a fait l'émission
souffrante de jeu peu son émission
[Rires]
vous dire c'est vous votre émission sais
pas comment s'appelle mon la regarde
c'est comme vous seriez pas y ont cédé
quelque part des fois on connaît pas
vraiment la drees un rêve mais c'est
ouais ouais ouais mon art contre vous je
sais même pas ce que vous avez toujours
bouffe à taillette pas les gens savent
je suis leader tnt tous les vendredis je
te le souhaite
le petit nicolas
bienvenue les garçons que j'ai plein de
new york avec mes enfants adorent il
adore alors il si on est un peu
l'équivalent c'est kiwi c'est le petit
jean michel away qui a très peur de son
instituteur regardez la bande annonce de
ce nouveau film qui va peut-être donner
envie à nous inviter à regarder le petit
jean michel adore dire des bêtises je le
mattais une nuit avec un anaconda
havrais d'accord anaconda comme ça et
quand je me suis réveillé j'attends
qu'on me caresser mais ça ne plaît pas
du tout à son instituteur qui fait très
peur
le petit jean michel a souvent du mal à
s'exprimer dans le toit posthume sans le
raclage en tout cas été pénalisable bon
temps dans les films disques de quoi
mourir ni d'ailleurs il n'a pas encore
mué jean-michel adom de toute façon
c'était l'émission
[Musique]
les nouveaux c'est vraiment nous moquer
des procès où il adore ça fait combien
de temps que tecmo après 9 en avril
wen qui passe de trop s'avancer plus
haute avec moi dix neuf de trop tiens à
vous dire un truc je regarde tout à
l'heure vous est radieuse c'est vrai ben
je suis là dommage que j'ai pas 60 ans
alors qu'il y avait soixante on se
revoit dans quelques années allez hop
avec ça vous savez que j'ai toujours
admiré votre créativité incroyable pour
trouver des noms de séquences des
chiffres et des remarques lâche
investigations touche pas à mon post it
mais depuis quelques temps ensemble pour
les noms de séquences moines brainstorm
qu'avant vous voyez c'est normal c'est
la fin de saison on a en février quand
même donc c'est bon
alors maintenant toutes les séquences
appel face et quelque chose va regarder
aussi tout ce qui s'est passé sur les
gossip on aura des nouvelles de céline
dion on va passer aux fastes end sportif
tout ce qui s'est passé et vous allez
voir on va passer tout de suite aux
infos téléski ne fallait pas manquer sur
le fast and kings on commence ce faste
mtv avec la boulette du jour
vous dire pourquoi les brunchs et qu'on
est très regardée outre atlantique et
des envies de centres concernés
comment moi je pense à scandale parce
que la preuve aujourd'hui vous lancez le
fast and mag et bientôt vous allez faire
quoi vous allez proposer le fast and
merguez vous en faites vous voyez un
objet et hop vous en faites une séquence
diallo fast and mc aujourd'hui elle
fasse un pas peut-être un rouge
[Rires]
alors en fait on n'est pas là moi je
découvre cette image il est batteur
qu'un j'arrive ici on ne peut pas dire
que je suis même pas au courant qu'il ya
le fast and flash effectivement c'est
nouveau et je sais mais ça a l'air très
bien sur vos chances
on va le faire ça à le faire voltaire
pas plus tard que dans une demi heure on
va le faire
enfin vous voyez un objet on fait une
séquence à on n'est pas le riz dont un
jour d'avoir une séquence qui s'appelle
le facetime poignées de porte
ouais et d'ailleurs tiens regardez ce
que c'est le fasse aujourd'hui dans le
faste et une poignée de porte les tons
métal ou encore les omnium les poignées
de portes suscite actuellement la
polémique
gilles verdez aurait même déclaré j'ai
mal à ma poignée de porc alors qu'elle
poignées de portes utilise bernard
laporte
à votre avis faut-il interdire les
poignées de portes en inox toutes les
réponses maintenant dans le faste une
poignée de porte
en général une personne normale attrape
la gastro une fois par an bon qu'elle il
attrape la gastro une fois par mois une
fois par jour par jour grâce à elle le
présent de smecta bien acheté une île
aux maldives est vrai que quand on a la
gastro querrien devient un peu de
discrétion on aime bien que personne ne
sache qu'on passe à 8 heures par jour
aux toilettes et malheureusement c'était
sans compter sur cyril la semaine
dernière je vous avais présenté hanoune
a tort
la personne qui flingue tout le monde et
bmp forcément aujourd'hui c'est hanoune
a tort
2la dernier texto qu'on a eue de cali
mais oui c'était en deux jours j'ai
perdu 8 kg kelly si tu nous regardes
bien entendu tu sais qu'on est là et si
tu as besoin demo diom on peut passer
alors oui gros rêveriez de dîner en tête
à tête avec marveaux redon
oui c'est les annales mange deux fois
chez ma mère frère pour aubiac
seebach technique je coupais je veux que
la veille trois fois chez ma mère c'est
mon cas
[Rires]
alors si elle n'était pas bonne je le
prépare ses fans un jeu c'est la cata
pas de couilles quand même comme un
personne n'est pas là tu y vas et quand
c'est devant ouais alors il ya eu trois
mots de trous des gens voulaient ces
retraités samoa que parler comme ça
laisse a surpris parce que vous voulez
mais bien gardé oui il y aura deux
vendredi vers 10h 18h à nous c'est très
simple c'est quand tu veux ou tu veux je
ne rigole pas demain je vais installer
un octogone on fera un combat en début
d'émission et assurera teinte avait pris
des airs de sel quoi moi donc tu as un
cours comme a dit franco va se calmer tu
me laisse le temps de trina des cours
j'avais dit que je prends quelques
courts et du bassin pas d'avion je vous
sais pas quand je veux où je veux c'est
quand vous voulez vous voulez en fait
c'est ce qu'on fera
mais te rends compte que si je gagne ça
veut dire que pour l'année prochaine tu
vas prendre un tout petit peu à fermer
ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien je vais m'en occuper dès
demain il a bien introduit dans ces
cas-là you're a rich qui me suit dégâts
sur un pool moi c'est encore un peu tôt
c'est encore un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le coupable nous fait chier
[Rires]
allez manger s'il rencontre qu'ils
étaient réduits qui les aident devant la
france je ne dis pas qu'il a tort
[Rires]
c'est celui qui paye alors vous dire
c'est pas parce que je paye que j'ai
tous les droits il a droit de dire ce
qu'ils pensent
malheureusement à partir de matane le
dira mais quand ils sortent de la sorte
comme ça viendra faire des photos oui ça
va faire des photos un stade etc sont
très amis vont discuter plus en plus
haut il faut dire tous les deux fans de
littérature au cas mon avis parler du
dernier closer même la chronique la plus
longue du monde
ah oui c'est clair mais j'adore quand
elle avait bel et bien camper cette
lumière fait pousser les cheveux tu vas
[Applaudissements]
encore lui ah ouais vas-y foncé de bras
c'est compliqué mais on a été magnifique
c'est partir avec nous je suis très bien
je pense aux heures avec vous il ya près
ça nous coûterait cher quand le manceau
première france 3 millions effectivement
série dans le monde n'y a que trois fans
de gilles verdez nom christophe
beaugrand mais celle ci mais c'est moi
c'est tout mais ce que j'adore celle il
sait quand il raconte des histoires
extraordinaires étaient encore endormis
la pluie ruisselle sur le bitume
le soleil se couche sur la jetée de
brighton sommes en 1993 en écosse sur
les bords du loch ness
[Rires]
doré de proposer à faire un dvd dont tu
as bien fait sur ces news et mes choix
et lui fait du mal ça va trop loin
oh la honte et les rentes des témoins
chaque voiture on vient aussi préservé
casser les voir qu'est ce qu'il a il m'a
saoulé excuse moi tu sais qu'on n'est
pas chez ta mère ici j'avais dit
qu'alliez vous appelez kelly long et au
fait je demande leur avis non pas à vous
aux artistes est ce que vous faites et
le jour chez nos wii voilà pour
l'instant thé devant les caméras tu
ranges les enfants c'est plus le patron
quitte pas c'est l'ami je vais te donner
un conseil je compte inquiète marc md
soit écoute toi je vais te dire un truc
je pense qu'il vaut mieux que tu sortes
du plateau à ce que sinon
malheureusement oui tu vas sortir de ce
plateau avec le nez péter mafany
attendait qu'il a pris des coups un euro
alors il a pris des coups après des
contrôles français de la rétention par
mathieu devient chaud là ça y est
[Rires]
alors qu'est ce qu'il veut je fais deux
mondes aux artistes et est-ce que je
peux revenir en plateau oui ou non cette
demande bien que je respecte ça fait
peur de mauvais comme ça le duo
département d'ailleurs marc sury
assieds-toi vous êtes plus d'artistes
oui oui oui à ces messieurs
c'est à ça qu'on trouve un jeu ce que tu
as fait c'est s'approcher comme ça à
moins d'un mètre la menace excusez le
lard et les mois sa force entre
stationné sa mort
alors faut refuser de série 6r la
chronique de 3 minutes et coûte mois
après mois plus tard côté moi je suis
content et même si en plus c'est celui
qui sont le plus bon de l'équipe mais ça
parce que tu es celui qui restent moins
longtemps plate couture ça fait du bien
alors pour finir je voudrais parler d'un
futur talent de la télévision matthieu
delormeau la future il a tout pour lui
il est grand et les bourians musclé
l'année une émission qui réunit 1
millions de téléspectateurs
enfin un million sans cumul l'audience
de 10 émissions mais y'a un truc qui
cloche c'est sont rien écoutez moi ça
allait mais qu'en fait ils sont
patrouille dans le quartier
[Rires]
à lancement de ce coup d'arrêt mais
reconnaît il est trop beau et ce qui est
bizarre c'est qu'en fait il fait le même
bruit que font les otaries alors j'ai
mis derrière de matthieu delormeau sur
les discussions entre otaries
franchement vois pas la différence
[Applaudissements]